sollten alle menschen einmal im leben
eine therapie machen einer der eine
klare meinung dazu hat ist der
systemische therapeut lukas mag ja ich
finde nicht dass jeder menschen leben
aber eine psychotherapie machen muss
weil psychotherapie das ist eine
medizinische behandlung für krankheiten
für psychische störungen die auch einen
krankheitswert haben und das hat zum
glück nicht jeder mensch am leben ganz
anders sieht das anke glasmeyer sie ist
psychotherapeutin und findet dann am
besten werden jeder und jede zwei mal im
jahr so wie es zum zahnarzt auch so
psychotherapeuten gehen würde um so
schon frühzeitig psychische erkrankungen
zu erkennen und dann zeitnah handeln zu
können
wir schicken die beiden einen tag lang
auf einen roadtrip beide haben eine
klare meinung aber keine ahnung was
heute passiert nur dass wir ihnen am
ende die frage stellen trefft ihr euch
in der mitte gibt es eine grauzone
einfach dass es für die gesellschaft gut
wäre da
lernen bewusstsein zu bekommen dass wir
nicht nur eine körperliche gesundheit
haben die viele bürger in ja auch eher
vernachlässigt und nicht zur
vorsorgeuntersuchung gehen sondern dass
es auch eine mentale gesundheit gibt und
die gepflegt werden es gibt auch viele
menschen die gesund bleiben da frage ich
mich dann sollten die zu einem
psychotherapeuten oder ein
psychotherapeut hingehen würde das also
da frage ich mich dann wozu weil ja auch
dieser satz jeder braucht therapien
wirkung hat und wenn ich meine therapie
auseinandersetzen und merkst dass es für
menschen die probleme haben wenn das so
ist ja so ein bisschen auch das stigma
und es ist ja auch eine medizinische
behandlung dann kann es auch passieren
dass ich mich selbst als kranker erlebe
als jetzt vielleicht bin
jeder sollte
unser erster stopp wird die beiden nach
walldorf dort treffen sie auf sarah und
die hat zu dem thema in ganz anderen
gedanken
was die personen seit ich ein teenager
und 14 ungefähr ihre diagnose depression
hat sie seit 2003 10 seit 2017 hat sie
insgesamt mehr als ein jahr auf
wartelisten verbracht jetzt hat sie zwar
eine therapeutin mit der klappt es aber
nicht so wie es sollte die lösung weiter
suchen und warten dass menschen dann
stehst du so mutig ist für unser test
häufigsten vorbereitung dass man so ein
bisschen das mal dass auf dem regelmäßig
auch beim vor tausend leuten dass das
ist mein
ausgewählte familie
ein bisschen was zeigen auch
wildesten werden sagen dass jeder
deutsche manuel therapie machen sollte
grundsätzlich es gibt dieses nie das
sagt ich muss in therapie war alle um
mich herum war ganz in sich zu gehen
ich glaube schon dass viele von uns das
bräuchten und das guttun würde auch
wegen stigma gegen verurteilungen also
ich habe jemanden im direkten verwandten
kreis der dringend hilfe bräuchte aber
aufgrund der generation einfach nicht
geht für das jetzt wird jetzt dieses
jahr 61 ja das ist nicht und
hat halt angst vor diskriminierung und
man ist ja auch diskriminierung
ausgesetzt auch ich aufgrund meines
alters weil ich bin ja viel zu jung für
depression stimmt das geht ja auch gar
nicht bin ja auch viel zu jungen irgend
eins zu sein um nicht arbeiten zu können
das werden die umsetzung ist natürlich
das schwierige wenn die dies hat schon
dringend brauchen und sich bewusst sind
dass sie es brauchen keine sätze kriegen
da noch so eingeschränkt sind in der
therapeuten war weil das muss stimmen
und wenn es dann so wenig nur gibt dann
ist es einfach und das er ausgeliefert
gestand stückweit ausgeliefert bzw man
nimmt halt das was man am ehesten
kriegen kann das habe ich halt auch
gemacht haben funktioniert aber im
zweifel nicht und das dann noch zum
beispiel krankenkassen oder andere dann
die idee ging ja ja es bringt ja gar
nicht mehr kommen wir hier gar nicht
woran es hat ja gar nicht mehr auf das
kann ich erst verstehen das ist aber
irgendwie ein bisschen hausgebackenen
sollte auf jeden fall mehr karte zu
geben damit jederzeit nach unterstützt
bekommt und halt nicht so wie du sieben
monate warten auf und wollten auch
länger aber dann geht es ja gar nicht
darum braucht jeder psychotherapie
sondern jeder mensch sollte die
behandlung und das angebote halten was
den bedarf mehr spricht dass man eine
anlaufstelle hat und dass eine
anlaufstelle hat die anderen in die
richtige richtung bringen können sagt
das ja du machst das auch ich mich auf
instagram aber ich war total mutig jetzt
heute gegen den austausch zu gehen also
es hat ja gesehen am anfang war ich
total ergriffen und das wollte ich ja
wahrscheinlich total prüfung nicht
deine erfahrung mitgeteilt hat also ich
glaube die sind auf jeden fall einer
meinung
dass
der gang zur therapie für alle
vielleicht eine lösung aber ist das
überhaupt realistisch wenn menschen wie
sarah so lange auf einen therapieplatz
warten mussten
mich interessiert wie bist du zu den
beruf bekommen also ich bin mit elf
jahren stocken geraten war mit elf oder
zwölf das erst in einer klinik und habe
da richtig scheiße erfahrungen mit
psychotherapeuten gemacht man hat mir
damals gesagt werden ob es ihr therapeut
ich mach veranlasst darf ich fahren
musste das für schlechte erfahrung war
und die dunkle macht das also wie gesagt
das genauso
man man hat über mich entschieden dann
zwang gearbeitet und das hat tatsächlich
das ganze eher verschlimmert ich habe
irgendwann auf eine magensonde gekommen
und da sag ich wirklich das war eine
psychische vergewaltigung also ich war
dann wirklich und so vier wänden
eingestellt und nur für mich raus und
muss dann im bett liegen
habe da ganz schnell ganz viel
zugenommen und es hatte überhaupt keine
psychotherapie dabei und weshalb
ich glaube also
in der systemischen therapie sagt man ja
gern so die erstgeborenen
übernehmen immer gern viel verantwortung
also in zehn jahren machen wir erst
gepasst hat alles geworden
war dass wir sozusagen in der
geschwister reihe schon eine rolle
kriegen muss mehr um verantwortung geht
natürlich gab es auch biografische
erfahrungen bei mir die
er dazu geführt haben zu sagen ich
möchte leuten helfen ich selbst bin ja
eigentlich auch was da kommen aus der
familie in der es zum 23 adhs leider
gibt es das ich habe eigentlich hätte
eigentlich auch eine diagnose
aber braucht dafür momentan ich hatte
das bisher auch nicht keine
psychotherapie geht mich immer darum
dass das ziel von psychotherapie sein
muss dass man geheilt oder gesund ist
sondern das war ein gutes leben führen
kann so man durch seine symptome durch
seine erkrankung bei der diagnose
eingeschränkt wird
der zweite stock bringt uns nach bochum
hier treffen wir jürgen makler schon
ziemlich wissen wo sie hinwollen uni
bochum der psychologe arbeitet als
professor an der ruhr-universität und
dort beschäftigt er sich mit der
entwicklung von therapiekonzepten und
der frage welche nebenwirkungen
psychotherapien haben es ist total
spannend weil wir gar nicht wussten wer
uns gleich wo gegenüber selbst abheben
schon mit jemand anderem nach
unterhalten habe und ich habe schon
einige bücher auch von ihnen gelesen so
hat doch mal ganz spannend und jubel die
dicken die
total spannend und wir haben es ja heute
so ein bisschen drüber unterhalten so
sollte jeder deutsche mal eine therapie
machen ist also würden sie auch eher
sagen dass es schon sinnvoll ist er so
prophylaktisch vorsorgung herzlich hass
zu machen also prävention wäre der
königsweg aber nicht im sinne von
allen alles also ich persönlich denke
wenn sie gute rahmenbedingungen schaffen
dann haben alle was davon das gilt für
alle aber ich glaube nicht dass alle
schon eine art heilbehandlung bekommen
sollten
dieser zeitplan voraus dass man ein
problem hat ich bin nicht der auffassung
dass
das man so machen sollte wie beim
zahnarzt also ich gehe zweimal im jahr
zum zahnarzt und also die zähne
durchchecken und wenn da was jetzt
wird's gemacht das ist beim zahnarzt
sinnvoll aber ich glaube beim
psychologen psychologin
psychotherapeutin würde ich denken
braucht das nicht aber sollte genauso
leicht sein zum
psychotherapie zu gehen oder zu
psychologie zu gehen wie zum hausarzt
und kann seine antwort darauf warum
aber lande führt hier nicht mehr geführt
werde warum die ak 40 ausgebaut werden
klar also ein
verteilungspolitik immer schwierig
umzuverteilen
wir geben nicht zu wenig geld aus für
die psychische gesundheit oder die
zusagen von psychisch ist aber umfeld
aber total schwer wie die da sind die
sitzen da und nix ab wir haben uns auch
nach über unterhalten in welchen ops
lebensphasen gibt in dem psycho therapie
vielleicht weniger sinn macht uns
einfach gerade im leben punkte und dinge
und gibt die vorlage aus sicht der
klient ein anderer patienten haben also
allen grund ein großen umbrüche phase
übergehen und so weiteres risiko fassen
die haben halt schauen muss man muss
eigentlich zweidimensionale models gibt
chance und es gibt risiken man kann es
ja oben entwickeln kann
und das heißt aber nicht dass man da
keine therapie machen kann ganz im
gegenteil sollte man möglichst rasch
wenn der probleme da sind eine machen
und vermeidet man das erst diese ganze
negative kaskade in gang kommt und
von daher gibt es eigentlich keine phase
und sagen kann dass das lohnt da nicht
oder ähnlich das anders als sagen wir
mal bei ästhetische chirurgie wo man
sagt vom alter von achtzehn solltest du
da gar nichts machen das bei uns ganz
ganz anders da hat mich gefreut
interessant drüber
das war ein sehr spannendes gespräch
ich weiß nicht dass er halt ganz viel
zum thema psychotherapie vorstoß jetzt
aber und dann jetzt wird ihnen so zu
quatschen war schon irgendwie nochmal
beeindrucken ich dachte mir so voll cool
das weil wir haben uns da wir jetzt im
zuge der diskussion eigentlich auch eher
angenähert und sowas gemeinsam es
entwickelt also die systemisch hat sagen
ja mal gemeinsame problem definition das
haben wir dann ja auch gemacht super
spannend und ich war auch christian so
schlau ist sagt
die letzte station unseres workshops
liegt genau in der mitte der ersten
beiden stationen in der kleinen stadt im
bergischen land wermelskirchen treffen
sich anke und lukas auch in der mitte in
der grauzone na ja also ich würde schon
sagen das ist allen menschen gut tun
würde aber ich bin so ein bisschen von
meiner meinung abgekommen jeder bürger
jede bürgerin
sollten müssen zweimal im jahr zu jahr
ab heute inne
sondern eher das ja das ist eine gute
versorgung geben muss mit guten
angeboten nicht nur psychotherapie auch
beratungen
sozialarbeit damen für muss einfach die
versorgung verbessert werden mehr kassen
sitze aber auch mehr
überprüfungen wie jetzt voll ist und
zwar ist die therapie dann ist für meine
haltung ich glaube ich bin so ein
bisschen noch einmal mehr in die
richtung gekommen welche bedeutung hat
eigentlich ein psychotherapeut in die
psychotherapeutin die idee zu sagen das
ist so was wie der haus also die
hausärzte sind für mentale gesundheit
das finde ich total spannend weil nur
dann kann man das ja irgendwie
bedarfsgerecht plan und das ist das was
ich so von heute mit dem jetzt habe ich
gar nicht so ein dicker weil ich dachte
nie dass das müssen wir eben nicht
machen dass da hab ich mich so ein
bisschen angenähert und auch noch immer
die wichtigkeit dass jeder der braucht
auch das richtige angebot bekommen soll
und da habe ich noch mal mitgenommen es
ist genug da das hast du auch gesagt ist
genug da und wir müssen nicht sparsam
sein sondern wir müssen das viele was
wir haben besser verteilen das ist das
was ich heute mitnehmen danke für den
tag hier war das hat mich total gefreut
jetzt unterhalten
[Applaus]
wie seht ihr das sollten alle menschen
einmal eine therapie machen schreibt es
uns in die kommentare
und wenn ihr wissen wollt die
betroffenen mit ihren problemen umgehen
wie schwierig die suche nach einem
therapieplatz wirklich ist und wie
arbeit und psyche zusammenhängen dann
schaut euch jetzt die ganze dokumente
generation depression in der zdf
mediathek an